"Humans eat hallucinogens, especially" magic mushrooms for more than nine thousand years
Even today, this natural fungus is used as an ecstasy drug, causing hallucinations
But how exactly does it work?
The main substance "psychologically active in mushroom" is called silosepine
When ingested, the body decomposes into the active compound seloxin, which reaches the brain
This begins to prevent the re-uptake of the neurotransmitter called serotonin, which increases its effectiveness
"Moreover, seloxin ... has a chemical structure similar to serotonin
Which means that it can stimulate the receptors in the brain and bind them
This overstimulated stimulus makes you realize and test things without any real stimulus
Which is known as hallucinations
These hallucinations may have ... a diverse nature of visual and acoustic sensations
Or introspection and insight
... although the experience may be very enjoyable
However, some drug abusers spoke about their experiences with abhorrent experiences
These feelings generally last from 3 to 8 hours
But it may look much longer because of the change of anesthetic for your perception of time
Scientists have also suggested that the brain ... may rearrange itself temporarily
... by preventing normal brain activity
And the creation of new, fully biologically stable brain connections
This makes it difficult to distinguish ... reality from imagination and amplifies the density of your thoughts
Making advance planning and conscious thinking almost impossible
We also see active areas of the hippocampus and the frontal cortex associated with dreams
Finally, emotional areas of the brain are activated chemically
It may lead to a sense of expanded awareness
Because the drug temporarily shifts the passages in your brain
"Become" thinking outside the box any creative "very natural"
... in a popular study in the United States
... "36 students from the universities were given the silosepine
They were monitored in the laboratory
One-third of respondents said it was one of the most spiritual experiences of their lives
And two-thirds put it among the top five experiences in their lives
... after two months of taking the drug
79% of participants showed signs of increased satisfaction and improved overall status
Family and friends were interviewed and confirmed these allegations
But not all mushrooms are positive
... where 22% of individuals are clinically tested
They felt frightened and suspicious at certain moments during their experience
Because of the state of their brains, they generally appeared as uncontrollable horrors
... although we still do not know much about magic mushrooms
However, it is not considered clinically addictive and causes little toxicity to other members of the body
In fact, a study in the UK found that it caused less harm to users and those around them
Compared to other narcotic drugs
Scientists believe that laws should change ... towards clinical testing of this drug
... in order to conduct advanced research
To understand the positive and negative effects of "magic fungus" on our brains